[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans votre
émission 7 8 le débat agression prise
d'otage tentative d'homicide est
exaspéré les surveillants pénitenciers
manifesté leur colère en janvier dernier
les prisons françaises saturé pourtant
le nombre de détenus de cesse de croître
pour faire face à cette surpopulation
carcérale une première réforme
judiciaire va être débattu la semaine
prochaine à l'assemblée nationale cette
vaste réforme entend notamment revoir le
sens et l'efficacité des peines serait
ce suffisant pour éviter les
débordements prison ces mesures reportée
par la loi sont elles applicables
comment cela peut se traduire dans les
prisons yvelinoise pour répondre à ces
questions j'accueille autour de cette
table la députée yvelinoise ya et lebron
peavey présidente de la commission des
lois à l'assemblée nationale ainsi que
will i say et buzz secrétaire local snp
fo de la maison d'arrêt de bois d'arcy
et enfin pascal oui oui nous sommes
délégué régional de l'union syndicale
des magistrats pour soir à vous tous et
merci d'avoir accepté cette invitation
alors il ya presque un an jour pour jour
il y avait déjà une manifestation des
surveillants pénitentiaires de bois
d'acier comme on peut le voir sur ces
images
est ce que cette manifestation avait
fait suite notamment une série
d'agressions déjà ou plutôt encore
est-ce que depuis un an la situation n'a
pas changé
vous savez la situation des prisons est
très compliqué tant qu'on résoudra pas
le problème de nombre de places le
nombre de lits
les problèmes de seront ne seront jamais
résolues malheureusement vous savez
quand vous avez trois détenus dans neuf
mètres carrés c'est très compliqué pour
eux aussi bien pour eux que pour le
personnel
donc tant qu'on ne résoudra pas certains
problèmes malheureusement les problèmes
vont persister à cela s'ajoute
aujourd'hui les problèmes les détenus de
plus en plus dangereux et les tenues
radicaliser malheureusement quand césar
que les caisses que vous appelez vous
des détenus de plus en plus dangereux
parce que notamment dans une maison
d'arrêt ce sont les personnes qui
attendent leur procès ou alors qu'ils y
purgent des peines on va dire inférieure
à deux ans de prison tout à fait le
problème c'est qu'à l'heure
d'aujourd'hui on se retrouve avec des
gens des détenus mélangés à des
condamnés alors qu'officiellement ça ne
se fait pas le problème le problème des
places fait qu'on en est là aujourd'hui
donc il ya des détenus qui n'ont pas
leur place en maison d'arrêt parce
qu'ils sont déjà jugés et d'autres
attendent attente de leur jugement et
qui sont très dangereux donc tant qu'il
ya pas une reclassification des
établissements par rapport à la
dangerosité des détenus
on en sera toujours au même point
d'accord ce jardin compris le taux
d'occupation notamment des pressions et
de france et de 200% il me semble est-ce
que selon vous les juges et magistrats
donnent trop facilement justement des
peines de prison les peines de prison
qui sont prononcées sont ces constats
aussi d'une société dans laquelle la
violence est de plus en plus importante
la délinquance est de plus en plus
également préoccupant c'est assez les
personnes jugées qui sont plus violentes
l'exigence de l'association delà d'une
part la délinquance d'autre part de sa
gravité
les réponses pénales elles sont très
diversifiés la prison ne vient que dans
l'ultime solution
après avoir envisagé d'autres peine
c'est-à-dire que les personnes sont
condamnées à des peines de prison
c'est des personnes qui ont ce qu'on
appelle des antécédents c'est pas la
première fois qu'elle passe au tribunal
c'est exceptionnel que la juge prononce
une peine de prison ferme à l'égard
d'une personne qui n'est jamais allé
avant devant un tribunal
d'accord tant que c'est à dire ce sont
surtout des récidivistes c'est à dire
que
un échec du rôle de la prison quelque
part alors un échec aussi un échec
social en général parce que souvent
c'est des personnes qui ont un parcours
je dirais malheureusement socialement
d'échecs successifs ce soit dans le
milieu du travail de la formation
professionnelle qui souvent d'ailleurs
fait complètement défaut des problèmes
de désocialisation des problèmes de
santé également et des problèmes souvent
également familiaux de rupture familiale
important don qui n'excuse rien mais qui
peuvent expliquer les comportements les
passages à l'acte les récidives
et effectivement les échecs successifs y
compris de prise en charge sociale
mais est-ce que le premier problème
notamment des places de prison en france
ce qu'elles ne sont pas suffisamment
nombreux sont notamment sur regard la
france et souvent condamnés pour la
surpopulation carcérale cependant si on
regarde le propre or seulement la
population
la france n'en président présente
beaucoup moins que la moyenne européenne
ou par rapport aux autres pays
est-ce que c'est pas plutôt ça qu'il
faut voir ce que l'on sait c'est que
cette difficulté relative à la
surpopulation carcérale fait que ça
paralyse toute action en fait toute
action à l'intérieur des prisons qui
vise à réinsérer détenus ça entraîne des
difficultés avec le personnel parce que
ça entraîne des tensions comme le
rappelait monsieur quand vous avez des
détenus qui ne sont pas occupés dans la
journée qui sont à 3 dans neuf mètres
carrés c'est des détenus qui même si
quand ils sont rentrés en détention
n'ont pas forcément de caractère de
dangerosité avérée vont être soumis à
une grosse tension qui va faire que il
va y avoir parfois des agressions de
personnels ou des agressions de détenus
entre donc cette difficulté de
surpopulation carcérale elle paralyse
toute politique pénale centrer vers la
réinsertion des détenus donc il faut
impérativement s'attaquer à ces
difficultés et il y a deux moyens pour
s'attaquer à ces difficultés
construire des places de prison bien
évidemment pour augmenter la capacité du
parc carcéral espérions avait annoncé
notamment
dix mille prison notamment alors même
temps l'as de prison le président de la
république dans le plan pénitentiaire a
annoncé la construction de 7000 places
de prison parce que le deuxième volet
c'est d'agir sur les peines alternatives
à l'incarcération d'une part donc pour
éviter que des personnes qui aujourd'hui
vont en prison
iai et donc leur proposer des peines
plus adaptées à leur profil est
également travaillé sur la réinsertion
pour faire en sorte que la prison
devienne enfin un moment utile utile
pour la société pour que la personne qui
fait un passage en prison ne recommence
pas quand elle sort de prison qu'elle ne
recommence pas à commettre une
infraction donc elle n'y retourne pas en
tout cas qu'elle n'y retourne au moins
donc il faut vraiment agir sur ces deux
volets là pour avoir une politique
pénale qui marche sur ses deux jambes en
matière pénitentiaire construire des
places est également agir sur les
entrants en prison d'accord notamment le
président de la république avait
également annoncé qu'ils ne voulaient
plus d'incarcérations pour les détenus
condamnés à moins d'un mois de prison
naïvement je pensais qu'il y avait une
séparation des pouvoirs en france donc
est ce qu'il ya vraiment le pouvoir de
faire ça s'il peut de bien sûr donner un
avis sur sur des réformes et d'ailleurs
il peut aussi enfin il peut pas porter
les réformes c'est le premier ministre
et le gouvernement qu'il élabore les
projets de loi mais en fait évidemment
ils le font en concertation avec le
président la république donc à ce titre
là il a le droit bien sûr d'émettre une
opinion mais en revanche évidemment il
peut pas à porter d'appréciation sur les
condamnations mail à son avis cela vie
qu'il aimait et les propos les projets
qui sont enfin des dispositions qui sont
dans le projet de réforme de la justice
concerne effectivement le fait de de
prévoir qu'il ne sera pas possible de
prononcer des peines inférieures à un
mois ça c'est possible de l'inscrire
dans la loi évidemment sa porte pas
atteinte en tant que tel à la à
l'indépendance des juges les juges savez
c'est un peu comme les peines plancher
quand y avait des peines planchers
c'était effectivement après c'est la
confiance qu'on peut avoir dans les
juges c'est différent
juste j'ajouterai simplement qu' il ya
quand même effectivement je crois que
c'est de mémoire dix mille peines
d'emprisonnement égales ou inférieures à
un mois bon alors c'est pas énorme par
rapport au volume total des peines
d'emprisonnement prononcées
quand on prononce une peine d'un mois
c'est que ça a du sens d'ailleurs de
manière générale quand on prononce une
peine quelle qu'elle soit ça a du sens
pour les magistrats en tout cas et
surtout pour les personnes qui sont
condamnées prononcé un mois
d'emprisonnement qui va amener derrière
a révoqué par exemple des peines
d'emprisonnement avec sursis
ça peut vouloir induire qu'il y aura
plus qu'un mois de prison à faire vous
voyez déjà on voit que la signification
d'une peine inférieure ou égale à moi
c'est pas simplement l'affichage du mois
de prison c'est également les
conséquences que ça par rapport au passé
pénal et au sursis puisque le sur six
ça laisse une peine en quelque sorte un
peu quand même beaucoup une épée de
damoclès sur la tête de quelqu'un
pendant cinq ans donc ça n'a pas
forcément le même sens c'est pas
forcément que un mois c'est un mois +
plus donc il faut tenir compte aussi de
ses éléments dans quinze jours les
régions alors simplement pour préciser
que toutes les peines de moins d'un mois
de prison ne sont pas prononcés en
prendre avec à l'esprit la révocation de
sursis ça peut être des cas particuliers
mais je pense qu'on est tous d'accord
sur le fait de se dire que en un mois
une personne détenue on a le temps dans
une maison d'arrêt de ne rien mettre en
place on a aucun accompagnement possible
donc c'est vraiment un mois qui vont
s'effectuer de façon très sèche avec un
choc carcéral absolument colossal pour
une personne qui pour qui ça peut être
une première incarcération est ce que ça
pêche pas vraiment svanir cepend très
très courte d'emprisonnement et c'est
vraiment l'objectif du gouvernement et
je pense que c'est un bon objectif
d'accor mais ce que justement ce n'est
pas justement ça le but ch 2
d'avoir des incarnations de très courte
durée pour que sa marque sans que ça
n'atteignent notamment les capacités de
réinsertion derrière alors pas du tout
les peines les très courtes peines de
prison sont extrêmement délétère elles
ne servent à rien et au contraire quand
une personne est inséré elle des inserts
absolument totalement une personne
leiria j'ai voulu intervenir par rapport
à ce que disent et la députée
concrètement moi il m'est arrivé de voir
des personnes arrivées un papier de 70
ans qui arrivait pour trois semaines en
prison pour un défaut de permis donc
cette personne mais vous l'avez détruit
tout en sachant qu il ya un passage
d'une semaine parce qu'on appelle le
quartier arrivants ils vont et évaluer
on va leur expliquer un peu comment
fonctionne l'établissement et ses
jardins sont complètement détruits et
par rapport au nombre de places je
reviens sur chose qu'on parlait tout à
l'heure
pendant la campagne moi j'ai eu la
chance de faire le débat d'entre deux
tours ou
monsieur manqueront promettait 15000
places de prison ça n'aurait pas résolu
tous les problèmes mais en partie
aujourd'hui on est à 7000 places de
prison une prison concrètement à partir
du moment d'aller terrain où tout est
signé il faut à peu près en moyenne cinq
ans pour la construire on va pas
attendre cinq ans qui est des morts pour
résoudre les problèmes je pense qu'à
l'heure d'aujourd'hui
pour l'organisation syndicale que je
représente
il ya des choses à faire dans l'urgence
on peut dans les médias
refaire une classification des
établissements par rapport à la
dangerosité comme je disais tout à
l'heure on regrette la fermeture de
clairvaux qui vont avoir lieu
prochainement qui est purement politique
donc parle de vétusté je peux vous
garantir que pas citer parce qu'il faut
pas comparer
mais il ya des établissements qui sont
bien plus bien plus vétustes il a raison
qu'ils sont ouverts aujourd'hui dans les
yvelines par exemple tout à fait ballon
va on va dire les choses honnêtement en
bois d'arcy je peux vous garantir madame
la députée est venu vous fait le
comparatif entre clairvaux et bois
d'arcy
il n'y a pas photo d'autant plus que
c'est un établissement qui a la mémoire
de la pénitentiaire il ya eu il s'est
passé beaucoup de choses et c'est un
établissement qui est très sécuritaire
donc ce qu'on regrette nous aujourd'hui
et un penser qu'avec le changement de
président il y aurait une machine
arrière constate que malheureusement on
est toujours au même point clairvaux est
fermé et je peux vous garantir que c'est
un établissement à l'heure d'aujourd'hui
un des plus sécuritaires si ce n'est le
plus sécuritaire réaction alors en fait
aujourd'hui justement et c'était le sens
des travaux que nous avons mené à
l'assemblée nationale nous avons mené
des groupes de travail de travail
relativement à la détention et je
dirigeais un groupe sur les
établissements à sécurité adapté et donc
les conclusions auxquelles nous sommes
parvenus savoureuse je vous rejoins
totalement ses dires il faut aujourd'hui
des établissements à sécurité adaptées
au niveau de dangerosité des détenus
donc des établissements à sécurité très
allégée pour les détenus non dangereux
le monsieur de 70 ans dont vous parliez
tout à l'heure qui est condamné pour un
défaut de permis et le détenu très
dangereux pour lequel il faut des
établissements extrêmement sécurisé il
nous faut cette palette d'établissement
que nous n'avons pas aujourd'hui
et dans ce cadre là moi je propose la
création d'établissements pénitentiaires
de réinsertion qui seraient des
établissements très allégée en termes de
sécurité et dans lesquels l'accent
serait mis sur la responsabilisation la
resocialisation
et ces établissements peuvent très bien
être constituée par des bâtiments qu'on
pourrait recycler tels que casernes etc
et sur ce point là la classe politique
dans son ensemble a est entièrement
d'accord il ya un consensus politique
sur ce point et l' avantage de ces
établissements c'est que notamment non
seulement ils ont des effets importants
sur la lutte contre la récidive mais ils
sont également moins onéreux plus
rapides à construire et les relations
entre les détenus et les surveillants
sont extrêmement pacifier ce sont les
éléments que nous avons que ce soit en
france ou à l'étranger donc je pense que
c'est des pistes extrêmement
intéressante et qui permet d'aller
beaucoup plus vite pascal
oui je vous les citer un exemple qui est
un peu l'expérience que j'en ai puisque
j'ai été juge de l'application des
peines à partir de 1987 encore au havre
d'abord puis à nantes et c'était
l'époque en 87 ou été mis en place les
seconds à pied blé les chantiers jet
avec un ancien amiral de la marine
l'amiral brac de la perrière
donc c'est et initiatives qui ont été
extrêmement intéressante puisque en fait
des détenus des jeunes détenus hommes de
toute la france pouvait être
effectivement affectés en fait dans une
maison d'arrêt de rattachement
et ensuite il était effectivement
orientées sur des camps des camps qui
étaient pris en charge en fait par des
personnels pénitentiaires mais aussi par
des militaires donc dans la dans les
forêts de l'oise c'était des chantiers
extérieurs qu'on appelle s'ils existent
toujours qui est une halte est une
possibilité d'exécuter sa peine on est
en prison donc on est sous écrou
mais on n'est pas dans la prison entre
quatre murs telle qu'elle existe
actuellement on est sur un lieu de
travail donc un chantier
alors qui peut prendre différentes
formes ça peut être effectivement une
prise en charge par exemple pour faire
réhabiliter par exemple des routes ou
des dérives nettoyer des rivières
réparer effectivement un certain nombre
de deux voix commune enfin des
effectivement des on va dire des
des biens des biens communs da des
missions d'intérêt général
donc le travail il est fait par les
détenus qui sont à ce moment là qu'ils
perçoivent quand même une rémunération
comme tout travail pénitentiaire et
l'encadrement est donc fait de telle
sorte que ils sont pas dans la prison
ils dorment pas dans la prison ça peut
être fait aussi dans des logements à
l'extérieur moi j'en ai fait au havre
dans des avec des chantiers de
réhabilitation il était dans un dans un
appartement avec l'association qui
existe notamment aujourd'hui dans les
yvelines escale au progès de
développement je serai pas vous répondre
ce que je suis plus juge d'application
des peines actuellement en tout cas pas
dans les yvelines et des chantiers
extérieurs il y en a effectivement dans
beaucoup d'endroits en france ça existe
toujours pour répondre à votre question
en revanche ça n'est pas suffisamment
développé pour différentes raisons et
essentiellement pour des raisons
financières pour des raisons on va dire
de financement cirque la miss à la
justice ne finance pas suffisamment de
structures sachant que c'est souvent
avec le milieu associatif
c'est à dire des associations
socio-éducatives du personnel qui est
compétent parce qu'il s'agit pas vous
encadrez pas des détenus comme vous
encadrez des scouts ont donc il faut
évidemment des personnels qui sont
formés à ça avec des perses
on va dire des publics un peu en
difficulté mais ça ça présente
généralement des très bons résultats et
je pense que c'est des solutions qu'il
faut effectivement continuer de
développer à côté celle que vous
évoquiez c'est à dire des établissements
effectivement on va dire de réinsertion
fin à vocation d'abord de réinsertion
plutôt que la sécurité des jeux suivants
le nouveau douze jeunes comme vous dites
c'est vraiment l'argent comment fait-on
et pourquoi est ce que cette fois ci
parce que cela comme des années qu'on
entend on va développer des peines
alternatives et on va essayer de trouver
d'autres solutions se fait des années
qu'on entend ce discours là pourquoi
cette fois ci ça devrait marcher parce
que
je pense que cette fois ci nous avons
d'une part une réelle volonté politique
de faire en sorte que cela marche
deuxièmement parce qu'un paravent pour
selon vous il n'y avait pas de volonté
du tout pas leur politique précédent ça
ne fonctionnait pas non mais je pense
que peut-être que ce n'était pas la
priorité peut-être que le moment n'était
pas venu vous savez parfois
la société n'est pas mûr parfois la
classe politique elle-même n'est pas mûr
parfois les intervenants les acteurs ne
sont pas mûrs pour vous savez il ya
pourquoi des conjonctions qui font que
tout d'un coup quelque chose marche
alors que la veille ça n'avait pas
marché par jean qu'il ya quelques jours
il y a
un sondage qui a été publié notamment
suite une demande de l'institut de jean
jaurès qui dit que près de la moitié des
français pensent que les détenus sont
traités de manière trop bonne qui
provient très hachée donc ce qu'il faut
vraiment pas forcément prêtes à entendre
ce genre de choses la population elle
est prête à entendre que l'on s'occupe
d'elle quand on parle des détenus c'est
à dire que quand on lutte contre la
récidive
on le fait dans l'intérêt de la
population dans son ensemble
on protège les futures victimes les
victimes de demain quand vous lutter
contre la récidive
vous luttez contre ça contre les
contrôles l'effet délétère aujourd'hui
de la récidive et il faut savoir
également que la récidive coûte cher les
places de prison à construire coûte cher
donc plus vous baisserez le taux de
récidive est aujourd'hui source cet
argent s'est développé ces alternatives
éviter les récidives
aujourd'hui une place de prison coûte
entre 130 et 300000 euros selon niveau
de sécurité
aujourd'hui c'est quelque chose qu'on
mettra en vente et le budget destiné à
la justice pour justement impliqués se
nommait le budget de la justice a
augmenté dans la dernière loi de
finances que nous avons votée il a
augmenté de près de 4% donc le budget a
augmenté mais tout n'est pas question
budgétaire c'est une question de choix
de soi politique de choix concerté pour
avoir une vraie politique se tourner
vers la réinsertion des personnes qui un
jour sont face à un tribunal ou à une
cour d'assises il faut absolument que la
société dans son ensemble comprennent
qu'on 9 hrs pour elle en oeuvrant pour
une plus juste aux politiques pénales
desai il ya un problème aussi c'est qu'à
l'heure d'aujourd'hui vous avez un
certain nombre de personnes qui n'ont
pas leur place chez nous qui au sens
qu'ils devront qui devrait être dans les
établissements psychiatriques
mais aujourd'hui on réfléchit avec la
calculatrice une journée en prison c'est
80 euros une journée à l'hôpital
psychiatrique ses 800 euros donc à
l'heure d'aujourd'hui on a beau dire ce
qu'on veut mais le résultat il est ainsi
qu on réfléchit avec la calculatrice
il ya des problèmes sur le terrain à
l'heure d'aujourd'hui on a un directeur
de l'administration pénitentiaire
moi je te dis je me suis mis incompétent
de la même façon comme
comme beaucoup de politiques réfléchi
avec la calculatrice c'est pas comme ça
qu'on va y arriver
directeur l'administration pénitentiaire
tout à l'heure il ya des problèmes
malheureusement qui ne sont pas qui ne
sont pas résolues à partir du moment où
prend pas le temps d'écouter les
difficultés qu'il ya sur le terrain
comment voulez vous avancez comment
voulez-vous résoudre ces problèmes là à
l'euro à l'heure d'aujourd'hui on en est
alain leleu le mouvement social qui a eu
lieu au mois de janvier
je veux dire c'est historique ça fait
une trentaine d'années que rien n'a pas
eu chez nous tout en sachant qu'on a le
on a on est sous statut particulier donc
on a officiellement on n'a pas le droit
de grève vous savez une fois qu'on en
est arrivé à là c'est qu'il ya un
ras-le-bol général
une réaction à côté de vous il y avait à
peu près 25% des personnes qui sont
détenues en france qui sont atteints de
troubles psychotiques qui sont les plus
graves maladies mentales
c'est à dire des schizophrénies des
pathologies les plus graves que même
paraît à la population ce qui s'appelle
à présent qui crachent jusqu'à comparer
la population je dirais à l'extérieur
c'est en population extérieure ces 3 %
c'est donc voilà le rapport donc si
effectivement et ça madame hazan qui est
contrôleur général des lieux de
privation de liberté l'a dit a écrit et
je crois qu'elle voulait également
exprimé ainsi que nous même quand on est
venu à la commission des lois
si on veut effectivement traitée aussi
une partie de la surpopulation pénale
j'ai une partie c'est pas que la seule
solution mais sortons effectivement de
des prisons ce car un quart des détenus
c'est énorme qui présentent des
pathologies des pathologies les plus
graves mais il faut effectivement
augmenté les places en milieu
hospitalier
c'est ça la condition je sais
effectivement c'est des chiffres que
nous était remonté on en a pas une
exacte connaissance parce que la
dernière étude épidémiologique est très
ancien mais
lorsque je vous parlais des groupes de
travail que nous avons lancé à
l'assemblée nationale un des groupes de
travail portait justement sur la
question du traitement psychiatrique et
nous proposons de développer ce qui
existe aujourd'hui un via de ce qu'on
appelle des yeux hsa donc des unités de
traitement psychiatrique des détenus
donc nous proposons de procéder à leur
développement je trouve que vous êtes un
peu injuste avec le directeur de
l'administration pénitentiaire je crois
que vraiment aujourd'hui nous avons dans
la majorité le souhait de vraiment
avancer sur ces questions là le
président a vraiment dans son discours
âge montrer l'ensemble du champ de
travail qui nous attend en la matière
les solutions sont très multiples essais
l'adjonction d'un certain nombre de
solutions qui fera que nous aurons réglé
ces questions là mais vraiment ne doutez
pas en tout cas de notre envie de
mobinautes mobilisation aborder ces
questions là très sérieusement en tout
cas vous ne pouvez pas de doute et de la
représentation nationale
nous avons depuis le mois novembre et
bien avant votre mouvement de
contestation mi la prison au coeur des
travaux de la commission des lois et
nous continuerons à le faire durant
toute cette mandature parce que nous
savons à quel point c'est essentiel et
c'est essentiel pour nous la réponse
faire des annonces c'est bien mais
concrètement
je pense que il faut aller au-delà de ce
qu'ils sont bien assis au chaud dans
leur bureau il faut prendre le temps
d'écouter la base et savoir un peu ce
qu'on a besoin réellement concrètement
sur le terrain parce qu'on en est là
aujourd'hui c'est des gens qui sont là
qui réfléchissent qui décide mais qui
sont déconnectés de la réalité du
terrain
aujourd'hui vous savez quand on parlait
de la peine justement le sens de la
peine à partir du moment où vous avez
pas de personnel pour gérer les détenus
c'est très compliqué donc il ya le
nombre de places effectivement les
annonces d'embauchés supplémentaires
mais on a beaucoup à vous annoncer
là on annonce 1200 1200 recrutement on
aura on les aura pas malheureusement le
constat il est là ça fait des années on
augmente les recrutements on n'a pas le
personnel adapté
pourquoi ça concrètement c'est simple
quand vous signez aux dépens il faut
savoir qu'un surveillant pénitentiaire
c'est un smicard il est même en dessous
du smic à l'heure d'aujourd'hui
une fois que vous avez enlevé la prime
le sheikh veillant c'est un smicard ça
fait des années qu'on demande
la parité police à partir du moment où
il y aura un peu plus de reconnaissance
tout passera par l'un des militaires et
le statutaire alors à l'heure
d'aujourd'hui en inde et alain parce que
on le sait les heures supplémentaires le
gouvernement veut les réduire veut même
les supprimer je ne dis pas je ne dis
pas qu'ils ont raison qu'ils ont tort le
jour on va y arriver on fera comment les
surveillants pénitentiaires à 1500 euros
elle se faire menacer insulter agresser
au quotidien est ce qu'une réflexion
vis-à-vis de ce alors justement en fait
la réflexion elle est diverse
elle est sûre effectivement le côté
indemnitaire mais pas seulement
c'est et c'est là tout le je pense
l'enjeu ces données en fait beaucoup
plus de sens à cette mission de qui ne
soit pas juste une mission de
surveillance mais qu'elle soit beaucoup
plus axé sur le contact sur la
réinsertion et sur un vrai travail
vraiment global par rapport aux détenus
et je pense que cela cédant vraiment
dans votre intérêt est ce qu'il ya des
propositions concrètes justement pour
faire évoluer les missions
alors il ya eu
un accord qui a été signé juste après la
coi qui a terminé en fait le mouvement
des surveillants
mais la réflexion de la garde des sceaux
se poursuit bien évidemment mai prochain
aura rien là dessus mais alors la
semaine prochaine je voudrais vous
corriger il n'y aura rien du tout le
projet justice va être présenté au
parlement mais on va être présenté en
conseil des ministres le 18 avril et le
travail parlementaire va commencer il va
venir dans l'hémicycle probablement
peut-être en juin ou en juillet donc là
on est vraiment dans la phase de travail
parlementaire qui va commencer et puis
je voudrais vraiment vous vous rappelez
noël tout le monde va sur le terrain
nous avions visité dans l'établissement
pénitentiaire la ministre de la justice
seront friands de te lancer quelques ce
en a plus que quelques secondes donc 30
secondes chacun s'il vous plaît vous
voulez tenter de réagir ce qui est très
important aussi pour diversifier encore
plus les sanctions pénales et
l'accompagnement c'est d'améliorer le
nombre de ces pays pca les conseillers
de probation et d'insertion
il est annoncé 1400 créations de postes
dans le projet de loi il faut savoir que
ces 1400 voix en créations de postes
c'est ce qu'on appelle purement et
simplement de la cavalerie parce qu'en
réalité ils étaient déjà annoncés sur la
loi de pénitentiaire de 2009 donc pour
l'instant c'est du virtuel
donc je rejoins ce qui a été dit tout à
l'heure vous avez raison il ya beaucoup
beaucoup d'annoncés mais malheureusement
les moyens et ils en font les moyens on
a pas on n'a pas le choix en france la
justice est trop et trop misérables et
la pénitentiaire aussi les derniers mois
s'il vous plaît alors concrètement pour
terminer tout passera par là des
militaires le statutaire comme on a dit
il faudra un dialogue social parce que
l'heure d'aujourd'hui il est interrompue
il faudra également évolué avec son
temps regardez un peu ce qui se passe
ailleurs
les détenus les plus dangereux il faut
utiliser les pistolets à impulsion
électrique ça se fait dans d'autres pays
les brigades cynophiles il faut les
utiliser on les a à un moment il va
falloir savoir ce qu'on veut où on le
fait ou
on fait rien ce sera le mot de la fin
merci beaucoup à vous d'avoir accepté de
participer à ce débat c'est frustrant
mais peut-être qu'on refera un autre
débat sur ce thème quant à vous je vous
invite à revoir cette émission sur notre
site internet à partager sur les réseaux
sociaux je vous souhaite une agréable de
soirée à la semaine prochaine
[Musique]